موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا بكم
هاي من الخلاف على اجتماعي وزراء دفاع
دولي حلف الناتو في قاعده رمشتاين الجويه
بالمانيا
الالمانيه او السماح للدول الاخرى بذلك
هذا هو قال وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيين
الالمانيه في بولندا
نقلت رويترز عن مسؤول رفيع في الاداره
الامريكيه ان مسؤولين امريكيين كبار نصحوا
اوكرانيا بتاجيل شبه هجوم كبير على القوه
الروسيه الى حي حصولها على امدادات اضافيه
من الاسلحه الامريكيه والتدريب على
استخدامها
بدوره قال رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه
الامريكيه الجنرال مارك ميلي انه سيكون من
الصعب بحر القوات الروسيه خلال العام
الحالي من كل جزء احتلته في اوكرانيا
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه سيطره على
بلده كشف كالواقعه جنوبي باخ مطفي منطقه
شرقي اوكرانيا وكانت تامرع الروسيه قد
اعلنت امس سيطرتها على البلده التي تقع
على بعد تسعه كيلو مترات الجنوبيه بحمض
قال للمتحدث
وانه سيتم فرض عقوبات اضافيه عليها
الرئيس الروسي يعتمد عليها بشكل متزايد
اعلن احتلافه والكرامه المعارض في تونس
اعتقال الشرطه احلي رئيس كتلته النيابيه
في البرلمان المنحل سيف الدين مخلوف وقد
ندى تلاف الكرامه في بيان بما اعتبرها
احكاما قضائيه عسكريه جائره بحق خمسه من
قياداته
ادواتهم رئيس جبهه الخلاص التونسيه
المعارضه احمد نجيب الشاذلي ما وصفها
بسلطه قيس سعيد بالسعي الى الانتقام من
خصومه السياسيين عبر سجنهم ومتابعتهم
قضائيه
الذي كان رئيس التونسي قيس سعيد الى ضروره
تصدي لكل المفسدين ممن يعتقدون انهم فوق
القانون على حد تعبيره
تلقت محكمه العدل الدوليه طلبا رسميا من
الجمعيه العامه تحليل للامم المتحده بجانب
ابداء الراي والتبعات القانونيه لاحتلال
اسرائيل الاراضي فلسطينيه وفي بيانها وضحت
المحكمه المسائل التي طلبت فيها الامم
المتحده الراي وهي تابعه القانونيه
الناشئه عن الانتهاك المستمر من قبل
اسرائيل لحقوق الفلسطيني
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]